for the past couple of months i've been
really enjoying my 16 inch m1 max
macbook pro for everything like snappy
web browsing on a daily basis the
incredible battery life that can last
days without needing a charge the
beautiful new mini led display for
watching shows and movies and of course
high performance for doing things like
photo editing in photoshop and video
editing in final cut pro but intel amd
and nvidia have been showing off new
processors and graphics chips at this
year's ces which will be going into new
laptops as soon as the end of this year
and from the looks of it apple's macbook
pro is gonna be seriously challenged on
every single front and even though the
m1 max is truly impressive for things
like video and photo editing programming
music production and more there are
still some areas where the m1 max just
isn't that great because of a lack of
proper software support take gaming for
example where the only optimized game
right out of the box is world of
warcraft which performs exceptionally
well when compared to a desktop rtx 3080
gpu but other than that the fps numbers
that we got in games that rely on
rosetta 2 translation and apps like
crossover 2.1 just weren't that
impressive and those are the games that
are actually supported since the latest
directx 12 api currently has zero
support with crossover and then if we
take a look at other things like raw
multi-threaded cpu performance and apps
like cinebench r23 amd's best 5900 hx
chip from last year is already right
there next to the 14 inch m1 max and
then going further looking at graphics
rendering performance the new blender
3.1 alpha build greatly improved
performance for many of the tests that
we ran
but the rtx 3080 within the razer blade
was still faster overall and it's even
worse for other rendering apps that
don't have decent support and to make
things worse intel amd and nvidia have
just unveiled some incredibly impressive
mobile chips that are gonna fly past
even the best version of the m1 max chip
so without further ado let's jump right
into some ces keynotes starting with
intel's our 12th gen h-series delivers
up to 40 percent higher performance than
our prior generation and there you go
they just unveiled the new 12th
generation mobile chips and these things
look promising look at that up to five
gigahertz clock speeds up to 14 cores
combining performance and efficiency
cores just like the m1 max is doing
these things are going to be very
powerful especially since they're saying
up to 40 percent higher performance gen
over gen and within their keynote intel
actually claimed that their new i9
processor is going to be faster than
apple's m1 max chip so check out this
chart right here you could see this is
basically a copy of what apple showed
off at their last event showing the m1
max having better performance per the
power that it uses better than the 5900
hx as you can see in that red line and
better than the last i9 11 980 hk and
you can see their new i-912 900 is above
and beyond what the m1 max can do which
is incredibly impressive and based on
this i fully believe when we actually
get them in our hands that those chips
are gonna have more raw performance than
the m1 max which is really disappointing
because with the m1 max chip it only got
better graphics performance instead of
better cpus now however the caveat is
that intel says that they'll use up to
115
watts of maximum power which is a ton
literally a ton of power as you can see
in this chart right here you can see
that a lot of these chips are using up
to 115
the i7s and the i9s the i5s actually go
up to 95 watts now keep in mind that
when we tested the m1 max ship the
maximum amount of power that it gave to
the cpu was 30 watts yes that's 30
instead of 115 so it kind of makes sense
why these alder like chips would be
faster and if you're wondering just how
much faster the new alder lakes are
going to be we already compared the m1
max 16 inch to the razer blade which had
the i9 11 900 h and in geekbench 5's
multi-core cpu test it scored up to 9300
points so the m1 max still had a good
lead but if you look over to how much
the top of the line 11 980 hk scored
that scored up to 10 000 points so if
you apply intel's 40 improvement we
should be getting around 14 000 which
will technically beat the m1 max and i'm
sure it'll do even better in cinebench
r23 so with that said i think there's a
pretty good chance that even some of
intel's i7 chips will be able to
outperform
the m1 max in terms of raw cpu
performance now that doesn't mean real
world performance and real task because
we are going to be testing that out as
soon as we get those new laptops so
definitely subscribe right now so you
don't miss out on those in-depth
comparisons but i guess we'll see and
finally intel did show off a new
technology which is very surprising
apparently they're going to be able to
integrate your iphone and your apple
watch with their new laptops and pcs so
you're essentially going to be able to
read your imessages through an intel
based pc which is very impressive and
one of the things that really
disappoints me about the new macbook pro
is that it does not support wi-fi 6e
which every single intel alder lake chip
is going to support so that's very
disappointing because i could have
bought a new wi-fi 6e router but i chose
wi-fi 6 instead because i just don't
have that on my macbook pro and the last
thing intel showed off was their new
deep link technology which basically
uses the integrated gpu within the alder
lake chip and the discrete intel arc
graphics chip together to improve
encoding speed by up to 1.4 times which
is actually very impressive so i guess
we'll see how that compares to the m1
max ship when we get our hands on those
and now let's move on to amd because
they also introduced some very
impressive laptop chips so let's listen
hey i'm proud to launch our amd ryzen
6000 series mobile 6000 series that
deliver leadership performance battery
life and much much more all right check
this out it's their zen 3 plus so it's
basically updated but the cool thing is
that it's on the new six nanometer
technology the new process node so it's
gonna be gaining in terms of efficiency
as well as performance with boost speeds
up to five gigahertz we're delivering an
average of 1.3 x faster performance
compared to the 5000 series now if you
didn't know how fast the amd chips were
check this out in terms of geekbench 5
the m1 max macbook pro was basically
killing the last top of the line 5900 hx
mobile chip that amd had so that's 12
600 compared to 9000 however if you
bring it into cinebench r23 you can see
right there that the 5900 hx is
literally right behind the m1 max in 100
cpu workloads now imagine adding 1.3
times to that number with the 6000
series yes it looks like it's gonna
destroy the m1 max chip and they might
even have some lower end models that are
going to be at the same level or even
outperform it so it's a little bit
disappointing that we don't have that
much cpu performance with the m1 max and
this right here is the real kicker amd
says that they're getting up to 24 hours
of battery life on a laptop now that's
probably using a laptop with a 99 watt
hour battery just like the 16 inch
macbook pro but it's because of the new
six nanometer process technology they
have the new power management they have
the new adaptive power control so
basically with all that said they say
they're getting up to that much now i'd
have to see it to believe it because we
tested the previous razer blade and it
had a horrible battery life so i guess
we'll have to test it out and see and
now getting to the next section they
have their new amd apus which is
basically a cpu with an integrated gpu
but here they're showing off their new
amd rd and a2 graphics architecture and
here you can see some pretty massive
gains in terms of fps compared to the
previous chips like the 1165 g7 which
goes into smaller 13-inch laptops look
at that 303 percent more fps and doom
eternal and a more popular title which
is cs go 146
so this basically shows that they're
gonna have actual competitive laptops
without dedicated graphics that you
could actually play games with and the
best part is that you have decent gaming
support with windows 11 instead of the
crappy situation with mac os where you
don't have that many games that are
supported and right here they're showing
off some new specs like for example they
got gen 4 pci express usb4 but as you
can see they have wi-fi 6e just like
intel and bluetooth low energy 5.2
compared to this macbook pro which just
has 5.0 which is also something that's
disappointing of course you have ddr5 on
those new chips and they also have hdmi
2.1 which the macbook pro does not have
unfortunately and apparently they also
have an av1 media engine which is also
nice for the windows side and finally
this slide is showing off that they're
gonna have these new chips into
notebooks or laptops starting february
so next month we're going to be getting
in these new laptops and comparing them
to this 16-inch macbook pro and now with
that said let's finally finish off with
nvidia's keynote and here they're
showing off a new rtx 3080 ti mobile
chip for laptops and this looks
absolutely insane basically the fastest
graphics in laptops ever and i fully
believe it's gonna outperform the m1 max
like crazy especially since they're
showing off up to 16 gigs of the fastest
gddr6 vram which is going to be very
impressive and what's blowing my mind is
that those laptops are going to start at
2500
which is exactly what this 16 inch
macbook pro starts at but that's without
the m1 max chip you actually have to pay
more especially if you want the fully
loaded you're paying 3 500
and then going further they showed off
the 3070 ti starting at only 1500 and
there's a chance that that chip is also
going to outperform the m1 max in terms
of graphics rendering and gaming and
other tasks like that which is crazy
like these guys are coming back with so
much performance at such a great value
it's just so impressive and one thing
that blew my mind was this chart in
terms of graphics rendering apps and
here they are showing off some massive
performance gains compared to a m1 max
macbook pro 16 inch like for example
blender cycles they're showing 10
compared to
153 in terms of minutes now obviously
that does not make sense and that's with
the blender cycles that does not support
the gpu that's actually cpu based and as
we know the new alpha build 3.1 of
blender finally supports it and it
definitely sped it up for us so you
shouldn't rely on this chart because
it's not showing the new alpha version
but i think what's the most accurate is
to look at redshift because redshift is
what apple used in their charts when
they showed off the m1 max ship so here
you can see 10 minutes instead of 28
that's almost three times faster and i
fully believe that this is realistic and
these chips are gonna be that much
faster than the macbook pro for graphics
rendering like that with that said i'm
very impressed with intel's nvidia's and
amd's ces keynotes because they're
showing off some very impressive gains
gains that i was not expecting at all so
this is very impressive and i'm excited
to get those in my hands so if you have
any thoughts on those keynotes or those
new chips definitely comment them down
below and if you're not already
subscribed do so right now because you
don't want to miss out on those laptop
comparisons compared to the m1 max so
thank you guys for watching check out
one of those two videos right there and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]